Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Once more unto the breach, dear friends, once more, or close the wall up with our English dead. In peace, there's nothing so becomes a man as modest stillness and humility. But when the blast of war blows in our ears, then imitate the action of the tiger, stiffen the sinews, summon up the blood,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。亲爱的朋友们，再次冲向缺口，再次冲锋，或者用我们英国人的尸体填满城墙。在和平时期，没有什么比谦逊和沉稳更能衬托一个人的气质。但当战争的号角在我们耳边吹响时，就要模仿老虎的动作，绷紧肌肉，唤醒热血，
disguise fair nature with hard-favoured rage. I see you stand like greyhounds in the slips, straining upon the start. The game's afoot. Follow your spirit, and upon this charge, cry God for Harry, England and St. George. Brilliant, Dominic. Yeah.
用凶猛的怒火掩盖温和的本性。我看着你们像系在皮带上的猎犬，蓄势待发。战斗开始了。追随你们的灵魂，在这次冲锋中，为哈里、英格兰和圣乔治高呼上帝之名。太精彩了，多米尼克。是的。
Isn't that basically the whole reason you've done the podcast is so that you can have the chance to read that speech? I've never done that speech before. It's a very moving moment. Well, you did it very well. Very stirring. So that is, of course, from Shakespeare's Henry V, the supreme epic of English martial achievement.
这难道不是你做这个播客的全部原因吗？就是为了有机会朗读那段演讲？我以前从未读过那段演讲。这是一个非常感人的时刻。嗯，你读得非常好。非常令人振奋。当然，这段话出自莎士比亚的《亨利五世》，这是英国军事成就的巅峰史诗。
And that is Henry, the hero king's call to arms at the siege of Harfleur. And those lines, God for Harry England and St. George, that's the kind of thing that you see in tabloid newspaper sports sections when England are about to play the Germans. And our boys have been kicking over tables in peaceful French squares. Exactly. I mean, that's one of those Shakespearean lines that, you know, nothing of Shakespeare. You've never seen a single Shakespeare play, but it's entered the folk memory and the national
那是亨利，这位英雄国王在哈弗勒尔围城战中的战斗号召。而那句“为哈里、英格兰和圣乔治高呼上帝之名”，就是你在小报体育版上看到的那种话，当英格兰即将对阵德国队时。而我们的男孩们一直在法国宁静的广场上踢翻桌子。没错。我的意思是，那是莎士比亚的经典台词之一，你知道的，即使你对莎士比亚一无所知，从未看过一部莎士比亚戏剧，它也已经进入了民间记忆和民族
imagination, hasn't it? Even at the most kind of demotic level. Yeah, absolutely. And the setting is the late summer of 1415 and the English under Henry are laying siege to Harfleur, which is a port on the Seine Estuary in Normandy. And Henry, by this point, has been king for a couple of years. And he's basically a bit bored with just being king of England. So he decides that he'd like to be king of France as well and launches an invasion. But I mean, he doesn't just decide, Tom. He
想象力中，不是吗？即使是在最通俗的层面上。是的，绝对是。背景是1415年的夏末，亨利率领的英军正在围攻哈弗勒尔，这是诺曼底塞纳河口的一个港口。到这个时候，亨利已经当了几年国王了。他基本上对仅仅做英格兰国王感到有点厌倦。所以他决定他也想做法国国王，并发动了入侵。但我的意思是，他不仅仅是决定，汤姆。他
actually is the king of France. He has a perfectly legitimate claim. He does, of course, which is one that his great-grandfather, Edward III, had been prosecuting as well. And people who've listened to the four episodes we did on the Hundred Years' War, this is basically the Hundred Years' War Part 2. And it's the Hundred Years' War because Henry V decides that he's going to go and attack France, because otherwise it would be, you know, the Forty Years' War or the Sixty Years' War or something. It wouldn't be nearly as impressive. Yeah. And I guess that the focus of the previous two episodes for us as English podcasters
实际上就是法国国王。他拥有完全合法的继承权。他当然有，这也是他的曾祖父爱德华三世一直在追求的权利。听过我们关于百年战争那四集节目的听众都知道，这基本上就是百年战争的第二部分。之所以叫百年战争，是因为亨利五世决定去进攻法国，否则它可能就是“四十年战争”或“六十年战争”之类的了。那看起来就不会那么令人印象深刻了。是的。我想对于我们这些英国播客主持人来说，之前两集节目的焦点
was the two great victories of Crecy and Poitiers. But of course, the great victory that Henry V wins is probably the most famous of the lot, the Battle of Agincourt. Oh, by far. By far. And in part, it's because it's an even more startling victory. But in part, it is also, I think, wouldn't you say, because of Shakespeare, because it's immortalised in this extraordinary play. And his reputation as England's greatest warrior king is completely burnished and gilded by Shakespeare.
是克雷西和普瓦捷这两场伟大的胜利。但当然，亨利五世赢得的那场伟大胜利可能是其中最著名的一场，即阿金库尔战役。哦，远不止于此。远不止于此。在某种程度上，这是因为它是一场更加令人震惊的胜利。但我认为，难道你不觉得，部分原因也是因为莎士比亚吗？因为它被这部非凡的戏剧不朽化了。他作为英格兰最伟大的武士国王的声誉，完全被莎士比亚擦亮并镀金了。
It's impossible to say now, isn't it? Because it's so embedded in the national imagination. Henry V is one of the two or three best known monarchs of England. So it's impossible to imagine a world in which he wasn't because we're so used to it. So how much Shakespeare has to do with that? I mean, I think you're probably right, a lot. And there have been fantastic Shakespearean performances. Kenneth Branagh as Henry V.
现在已经无法分辨了，不是吗？因为它已经深深植根于民族想象力之中。亨利五世是英国最著名的两三位君主之一。所以我们很难想象一个没有他的世界，因为我们已经习惯了。那么莎士比亚在其中起了多大作用呢？我的意思是，我想你是对的，作用很大。而且有过非常棒的莎士比亚表演。肯尼斯·布拉纳饰演的亨利五世。
Olivier, of course. I mean, Olivier in the 1940s. Dominic, while I was preparing the notes for this, if ever my enthusiasm flagged, I would listen to Kenneth Branagh do the We Few, We Happy Few, We Band of Brothers speech on the eve before Agincourt, and it would always revitalise me.
当然还有奥利弗。我的意思是，1940年代的奥利弗。多米尼克，当我在准备这些笔记时，如果我的热情有任何消退，我就会听肯尼斯·布拉纳在阿金库尔前夕发表的“我们少数，我们幸福的少数，我们兄弟连”的演讲，它总是能让我重新振作起来。
So this is what I think sets the story of Henry V apart from the story about Edward III. Edward III, an incredibly impressive king, fights the Hundred Years' War, wins lots of battles, all of this. But Henry V, the idea of the underdog triumph against the odds, the idea of the band of brothers, we few, we happy few. I mean, that obviously plays a part. I mean, Nelson was obsessed with this and the idea of the band of brothers. And then in the Second World War, the idea of the few, once again, in the Battle of Britain, that gives it attraction that no other medieval battle has, maybe not even Hastings. Although, Dominic, I mean, of course, the victories won by Edward III and the Black Prince
所以我认为这就是亨利五世的故事与爱德华三世的故事不同的地方。爱德华三世，一位令人难以置信的印象深刻的国王，打了百年战争，赢得了许多战斗，所有这些。但亨利五世，那种以弱胜强的胜利理念，那种兄弟连的理念，我们少数，我们幸福的少数。我的意思是，这显然起了一定作用。我的意思是，纳尔逊对这一点以及兄弟连的理念非常着迷。然后在第二次世界大战中，在不列颠战役中，那种“少数人”的理念再次出现，这赋予了它其他中世纪战役所没有的吸引力，也许连黑斯廷斯战役都比不上。虽然，多米尼克，我的意思是，当然，爱德华三世和黑太子赢得的胜利
are also very much against the odds and reflect the fact that England compared to France is a relatively minor power. I mean, it's astonishing that Edward III went to war with France. And it's kind of astonishing that Henry V is going to war with France. I mean, it's a big ask, but for reasons that we will come to in the course of this episode, it's perhaps not as big an ask as it might have been in the previous century. So let's give it a bit of context. So we didn't mention France at all when we were talking about Henry IV. So the usurper king, Battle of Shrewsbury, all that stuff we did last week. And partly that's because there has been a kind of a truce in the Hundred Years' War. Yeah, it's a truce, but it's a kind of cold war as well. Right, because the English are still making a claim, aren't they? So the English kings are still, you know, nominally, they call themselves King of France.
也确实是在极其不利的情况下取得的，反映了这样一个事实：与法国相比，英格兰是一个相对较小的强国。我的意思是，爱德华三世与法国开战令人震惊。而亨利五世要与法国开战也令人震惊。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的挑战，但出于我们在本集节目中会提到的原因，这可能不像上个世纪那样是一个巨大的挑战。所以让我们提供一点背景。所以我们在谈论亨利四世时根本没有提到法国。那个篡位者国王，什鲁斯伯里战役，所有我们上周谈论的事情。部分原因是百年战争中出现了一种休战。是的，这是一种休战，但也是一种冷战。没错，因为英国人仍然在提出主张，不是吗？所以英国国王仍然，你知道，名义上，他们自称为法国国王。
And conversely, the French have not accepted the Lancastrians as the rightful kings of England. They regard Henry IV as Henry of Lancaster rather than King Henry. Yeah, so that's how they always address him. And I think that that is partly out of genuine shock that Henry has toppled Richard. The English now have a reputation among the French as people who kill their kings, and this is seen as a terrible thing. But of course, it's also a way of denying Henry the kind of legitimacy that he might then capitalize on to start pressing his claim to the throne of France. And throughout his reign, the French are always in the background. So we compared
相反，法国人并没有接受兰开斯特家族作为合法的英格兰国王。他们认为亨利四世是兰开斯特的亨利，而不是亨利国王。是的，所以他们总是这样称呼他。我认为这部分是出于对亨利推翻理查德的真正震惊。英国人在法国人中现在有了杀害自己国王的名声，这被视为一件可怕的事情。但当然，这也是一种剥夺亨利合法性的方式，他本可以利用这种合法性来开始宣称法国王位。在他的整个统治期间，法国人总是处于背景中。所以我们把它
it to the Cold War. The role that they are playing is like the Soviet Union sending military advisors to Vietnam or whatever in the more recent Cold War. So in Scotland, Hotspur's great victory at Humbleton Hill among the captives is a French captain. And in Wales, where Owen Glyndwr has been leading this incredible rebellion against English rule, the French recognise him as what he claims to be the Prince of Wales in 1404. And the next year, they actually send a military expedition to Wales. It lands at Milford Haven. And this kind of Franco-Welsh force crosses into England, which is almost as far as Worcester. So on the British mainland, France is causing trouble. And also in English waters, they're causing trouble.
比作冷战。他们扮演的角色就像苏联在最近的冷战中向越南或其他地方派遣军事顾问一样。所以在苏格兰，霍茨珀在汉布尔顿山的伟大胜利中，俘虏中就有一名法国队长。而在威尔士，欧文·格林多一直在领导这场针对英国统治的不可思议的叛乱，法国人在1404年承认他为他所声称的威尔士亲王。第二年，他们实际上向威尔士派遣了一支军事远征队。它在米尔福德港登陆。而这支法威尔联军进入了英格兰，几乎到达了伍斯特。所以在英国本土，法国正在制造麻烦。而且在英国水域，他们也在制造麻烦。
Yeah, the English don't have control of the seas, do they? The French have control. No, they've basically lost it. And Huffler is playing a key role in this. It's a kind of great nest of pirates, state-sponsored. And it's not just that they're preying on English shipping, but of course that they can launch raids on the southern English coast. So relations aren't great.
是的，英国人没有控制海洋，对吧？法国人控制着。不，他们基本上失去了控制。而哈弗勒尔在其中扮演了关键角色。它是一个由国家支持的海盗巢穴。而且不仅仅是他们掠夺英国航运，当然他们还可以对英国南部海岸发动袭击。所以关系不太好。
However, the previous two episodes we did on Henry IV, we were talking about how England really has been in a bit of a mess, you know, under Richard II and then under Henry IV. But it's fair to say, and this of course is always a comfort to the English, France, if anything, is in an even bigger mess. The French king, unlike Henry, Henry IV, and of course Henry V as his son, he doesn't have a crisis of legitimacy, but I think it would be fair to say he's not 100% on top of his game. And in fact, maybe of all the French kings, he is the man who could best do with a subscription to Better Help.
然而，我们在亨利四世的两集节目中谈到，英格兰在理查德二世和亨利四世统治下确实陷入了一团糟。但公平地说，这对英国人来说总是一种安慰，法国的情况如果说有什么不同的话，那就是更糟。法国国王，不像亨利，亨利四世，当然还有作为他儿子的亨利五世，他没有合法性危机，但我认为公平地说，他并没有处于最佳状态。事实上，也许在所有的法国国王中，他是最需要订阅“Better Help”（心理咨询服务）的人。
Better Help. I was thinking exactly that. Yeah. His mental health is very, very frail. He is in a terrible mess, isn't he? So Charles VI, he'd become king in 1380 and he was king for six centuries or something. Yeah, when he was 12. And we talked in the French Revolution, didn't we, about how French kings tend to be young. Yeah. But he's always having these breakdowns, isn't he? And the first one I read, 1392, it's because he's approached by a leper in a wood and that causes him to have a nervous breakdown. Extraordinary. He's on a military expedition, I think going off to Brittany and it's very, very hot. He's getting, you know, increasingly stressed and this leper looms out, grabs the bridle of his horse and
Better Help。我刚才就在想这个。是的。他的心理健康非常非常脆弱。他陷入了可怕的混乱，不是吗？所以查理六世，他在1380年成为国王，他当了六个世纪的国王还是什么的。是的，当他12岁时。我们在法国大革命那一集中谈到过，法国国王往往很年轻。是的。但他总是精神崩溃，不是吗？我读到的第一次是在1392年，因为他在树林里被一个麻风病人接近，这导致他精神崩溃。非同寻常。他当时正在进行一次军事远征，我想是去布列塔尼，天气非常非常热。他变得越来越紧张，这个麻风病人突然出现，抓住了他马的缰绳，
cries out, you are betrayed. And the king has this nervous breakdown and he takes to bed for several weeks. And then it seems that he's recovered from this. And then the next year, something even worse happens, which we actually discussed in our episode on the worst parties in history. And it's called by the French, the Balle des Ardents, the Ball of the Burning Men. And people may remember that it's a big party. The king and five of his lords decide that they will dress up as wild men of the woods and they coat themselves in tar and then stick branches and leaves onto themselves. And obviously they're aware that this is a little bit dangerous. So the king says,
大喊，你被出卖了。国王精神崩溃了，他在床上躺了几个星期。然后看起来他从这次崩溃中恢复了。然后第二年，发生了更糟糕的事情，我们实际上在我们关于历史上最糟糕派对的那一集中讨论过。它被法国人称为“燃烧者舞会”（Balle des Ardents）。人们可能还记得那是一个大型派对。国王和他的五位领主决定打扮成森林里的野人，他们用焦油涂满全身，然后把树枝和叶子粘在自己身上。显然他们意识到这有点危险。所以国王说，
whatever you do, you know, turn out all the candles. You can't have the candles. And then his younger brother, Louis, the Duke of Orléans comes in, says, oh, what are those costumes? He's got a torch, puts the torch up to look at them and he just goes, whoosh. And, you know, four of them burn to death and only the king and one other lord whose robes of court fire survive. Hot, hot, hot. Yeah. So that's that's not helpful to his mental stability at all. And by 1395, so two years on, he's claiming that he's St. George. He then starts worrying that he's made of glass. I love that. He worries that he's made of glass. So we talked
无论如何，你知道，把所有的蜡烛都熄灭。不能有蜡烛。然后他的弟弟，奥尔良公爵路易进来了，说，哦，那些是什么服装？他拿着火把，把火把凑近去看他们，然后就“呼”的一声。你知道，他们中有四个人被烧死了，只有国王和另一位穿着防火长袍的领主幸存下来。热，热，热。是的，所以这对他的心理稳定一点帮助都没有。到了1395年，也就是两年后，他声称自己是圣乔治。然后他开始担心自己是玻璃做的。我喜欢这个。他担心自己是玻璃做的。所以我们谈到了
about that, I think, also with Bartholomew, when we talked about Burgundy. I mean, he's very anxious, isn't he? I mean, he basically wants to be literally wrapped in cotton wool. Yeah. Because if you're made of glass, anything could shatter you. And obviously, I mean, this isn't an ideal condition if you're the king of medieval France, being menaced by England and a host of other enemies, but nobody thinks to depose him. So he is called Charles the Mad, but he's also called Charles the Beloved. And actually when he's lucid, he's perfectly competent. But the problem is as the years go by, the periods of lucidity become fewer and fewer and shorter and shorter. And so the fact that the king is basically out of action makes faction fighting kind of inevitable because that's always what
那个，我想，在谈到勃艮第时也提到了巴塞洛缪。我的意思是，他非常焦虑，不是吗？我的意思是，他基本上想被字面意义上地包裹在棉花里。是的。因为如果你是玻璃做的，任何东西都可能把你震碎。显然，我的意思是，如果你是中世纪法国的国王，受到英格兰和许多其他敌人的威胁，这并不是一个理想的状态，但没有人想到要废黜他。所以他被称为“疯子查理”，但他也被称为“受爱戴的查理”。事实上，当他清醒时，他完全有能力。但问题是随着岁月的流逝，清醒的时期变得越来越少，越来越短。所以国王基本上无法行事，这使得派系斗争变得不可避免，因为那总是
happens. Yes. So there are two great factions, aren't there? Each of them is led by a charismatic and very formidable character. Yeah. Both of whom are members of the royal family. So let's start with the first one. The first one is Louis, the Duke of Orléans. Now, he has slightly got a bit of a tarnished reputation because he's the fellow with the torch at the Balle des Ardents, the Ball of the Burning Men. So he's a cad, isn't he?
发生的事情。是的。所以有两个大派系，不是吗？他们每个人都由一个富有魅力且非常可怕的人物领导。是的。他们都是王室成员。所以让我们从第一个开始。第一个是奥尔良公爵路易。现在，他的名声稍微有点受损，因为他是在“燃烧者舞会”上拿着火把的那个人。所以他是个无赖，不是吗？
Or is he a bounder? Hard to tell the difference. I think he's more of a cad. So he's a massive womaniser. So Thomas Walsingham, the monk at St. Albans, who we've been drawing on a lot for these episodes, describes him as a man who is always taking his pleasure with whores, harlots and incest. Okay. And the charge of incest relates to the fact that he's said to have had an affair with the queen.
或者他是个混蛋？很难区分。我想他更像个无赖。所以他是个十足的女人。所以圣奥尔本斯的僧侣托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆，我们在这几集中大量引用了他的话，形容他是一个总是与妓女、荡妇和乱伦为乐的人。好吧。而乱伦的指控与他据称与王后有染有关。
So his sister. He's French. So I mean, this comes with the territory, doesn't it? Yeah. One may think that. And he'd been a very good friend of um henry of lancaster before henry became king and while he was in exile and then of course henry goes off and deposes richard ii and orléans feels incredibly insulted by this he feels that henry has stabbed him in the back that he's betrayed him well it's not all about him. As far as he's concerned, it is about him because he's getting criticised in France for the role that he's supposed to have played in the deposition of Richard II. So in a sense, the kind of the vigour of his hostility to Henry IV is an attempt to try
所以是他的姐姐。他是法国人。所以我的意思是，这随之而来，不是吗？是的。人们可能会这么想。他曾是兰开斯特的亨利在成为国王之前以及流亡期间的好朋友，然后当然亨利去废黜了理查德二世，奥尔良对此感到非常受辱，他觉得亨利在背后捅了他一刀，他背叛了他。好吧，这并不全是关于他。就他而言，这确实是关于他，因为他在法国因他在废黜理查德二世中所扮演的角色而受到批评。所以从某种意义上说，他对亨利四世的敌意在某种程度上是一种尝试，试图
and demonstrate the fact that he wasn't complicit in Henry's coup. Right. So Thomas, a little bit like if you launched a coup and I was embarrassed that you'd done this, I might then try to distance myself from you, but then kind of massively overcompensated and challenged you to a duel. Because this is what Louis of Orléans does, isn't he? Literally. Yeah. He writes to Henry and says, let's settle this man to man. You've let me down here. Yeah. And Henry says, no, not having any of it. But I think that exchange reflects Louis' character. He's very hot headed.
证明他并没有参与亨利的政变。没错。所以托马斯，有点像如果你发动了政变，而我为你这样做感到尴尬，我可能会试图与你保持距离，但随后又过度补偿并挑战你决斗。因为这就是奥尔良的路易所做的，不是吗？字面意义上。是的。他写信给亨利说，让我们一对一地解决这个问题。你在这里让我失望了。是的。而亨利说，不，我才不干。但我认为那次交流反映了路易的性格。他非常冲动。
He's very patriotic. He's a man who enjoys holding a grudge and nursing it. I like him. But he's also kind of very subtle and sophisticated. So a slight Captain Bentine quality to him perhaps. Sounds great. With the additional bonus of setting fire to people dressed in pitch. Yeah, and also the harlots and the incest, which Captain Bentine was a stranger to.
他非常爱国。他是一个喜欢怀恨在心并不断滋养它的人。我喜欢他。但他也非常微妙和复杂。所以也许有点像本廷上尉的特质。听起来不错。还有额外的好处，就是点燃那些穿着焦油衣服的人。是的，还有荡妇和乱伦，这是本廷上尉所陌生的。
Yes, let's put that on the record. So very much not the kind of person who would tolerate a rival, but unfortunately he does have a rival in the French court, and this is in the form of John the Fearless. And you mentioned Bart Van Loo, who did one of our iconic early episodes, didn't he, on the Dukes of Burgundy. And John the Fearless is the son of the first great Duke of Burgundy, who was Philip the Bold, who was the youngest son of Charles V. So Philip the Bold was the uncle of Charles VI. So John the Fearless is Charles VI's cousin. And John the Fearless rules this enormous agglomeration of territories of all the French peers. He's the guy who has the largest land and property. So it includes not just Burgundy, but also the County of Flanders. And over the course of his father's life and his own life, John the Fearless kind of basically,
是的，让我们把它记录在案。所以他绝不是那种能容忍竞争对手的人，但不幸的是，他在法国宫廷里确实有一个竞争对手，那就是“无畏者”约翰。你提到了巴特·范·卢，他做了我们标志性的早期节目之一，不是吗，关于勃艮第公爵。而“无畏者”约翰是第一位伟大的勃艮第公爵菲利普“大胆者”的儿子，他是查理五世的幼子。所以菲利普“大胆者”是查理六世的叔叔。所以“无畏者”约翰是查理六世的堂兄弟。而“无畏者”约翰统治着所有法国贵族中巨大的领土集合。他是拥有最大土地和财产的人。所以它不仅包括勃艮第，还包括佛兰德伯国。在他父亲的一生和他自己的一生中，“无畏者”约翰基本上，
I mean, he comes to rule pretty much the whole of the Low Countries. And of course, that then embroils him in English politics because the Low Countries are crucial to the wool trade. So the Dukes of Burgundy are always kind of midway, a bit between France and England. And this is an important part of the story. So to survey the scene, we've got Charles VI, who thinks he's made of glass and is bonkers.
我的意思是，他统治了几乎整个低地国家。当然，这随后使他卷入了英国政治，因为低地国家对羊毛贸易至关重要。所以勃艮第公爵总是处于法国和英国之间。这是故事的重要组成部分。所以纵观全局，我们有查理六世，他认为自己是玻璃做的，而且疯了。
And then we've got the two power brokers who are fighting for control in France. Louis of Orléans, incest, burning torches and grudges. John the Fearless, literally fearless, rules Burgundy and the Le Contre. And for those two guys, the important thing is who's going to control the heir to the throne.
然后我们有争夺法国控制权的两个权力掮客。奥尔良的路易，乱伦、燃烧的火把和怨恨。“无畏者”约翰，字面意义上的无畏，统治着勃艮第和低地国家。对于这两个人来说，重要的事情是谁将控制王位继承人。
The Dauphin. Because do they assume that the mad king is not long for this world? I think it's the fact that with the king out of action and the Dauphin is quite young, he's not even a teenager at this point. If you can get him under his thumb, then basically you have the rule of France. And the Dauphin is not a hugely impressive figure. So he will grow up to become an absolutely classic teenager, very kind of sulky, moody, getting up at midday, a bit fat, to be honest. People are always commenting on this.
王太子。因为他们是否认为疯国王活不长了？我认为事实是，由于国王无法行事，而王太子还很年轻，此时他甚至还不到十几岁。如果你能把他控制在手心里，那么基本上你就统治了法国。而王太子并不是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物。所以他长大后会成为一个绝对典型的青少年，非常阴沉、喜怒无常，中午才起床，说实话，有点胖。人们总是评论这一点。
Tom, you're fat shamed of the Dauphin. It's not me. I'm merely quoting his contemporaries. And so certainly at this age, he's quite a cipher as well. And so as a result, the Orleanists and the Burgundians are just kind of endlessly kidnapping the Dauphin and it's all quite bewildering. They really need to kind of keep track of all the ins and outs of it. But it's John the Fearless who essentially emerges triumphant from this tit for the tat Dauphin kidnapping because he gets himself appointed guardian of the Dauphin while the king is off being mad. And Orléans, the Duke of Orléans responds to this in 1407 in a very
汤姆，你在羞辱王太子的身材。不是我。我只是在引用他同时代人的话。所以在这个年龄，他确实也是一个无名小卒。因此，奥尔良派和勃艮第派只是在无休止地绑架王太子，这让人非常困惑。他们真的需要跟踪所有的来龙去脉。但正是“无畏者”约翰最终从这场王太子绑架的针锋相对中取得了胜利，因为他在国王忙着发疯的时候，让自己被任命为王太子的监护人。而奥尔良公爵在1407年以一种非常
decisive way. He has a clean out of the royal council and almost all the Burgundian sympathisers are kicked off. And then he uses the royal treasury to buy himself the Duchy of Luxembourg, which basically straddles the two territories that the Duke of Burgundy rules. So in the low countries and in Burgundy proper. And this is infuriating to John the Fearless, and they're gearing up to have another crack at each other. And Charles VI comes out of his madness, and on the 20th of November, 1407, he summons the two Dukes into his presence, and he presides over a very solemn reconciliation. And it ends with him saying, now praise be God, you have sworn solemn oaths, all is good. And it ends with him saying, now, praise be God. You have sworn solemn oaths. All is good. And then three days later, Orléans is murdered in Paris
果断的方式回应了这一点。他清洗了皇家委员会，几乎所有的勃艮第同情者都被踢了出去。然后他利用国库为自己购买了卢森堡公国，这基本上横跨了勃艮第公爵统治的两个领土。所以在低地国家和勃艮第本土。这让“无畏者”约翰非常愤怒，他们正准备再次交手。查理六世从疯狂中恢复过来，在1407年11月20日，他召集两位公爵到他面前，主持了一场非常庄严的和解。它以他说“现在赞美上帝，你们已经发了庄严的誓言，一切都好”而结束。它以他说“现在，赞美上帝。你们已经发了庄严的誓言。一切都好”而结束。然后三天后，奥尔良在巴黎被谋杀
by 15 masked assassins as he is mounting his horse. Wow. That's a twist. And the assassins get arrested. And it turns out that the guy in charge of these assassins is a personal servant of John the Fearless. So it's pretty clear who's behind it. And in fact, John the Fearless doesn't deny it. He commissions a professor at the Sorbonne to deliver a public lecture on tyrannicide and how it's justified. And you would think that for the king to have to swallow this as he does is an abject humiliation. And it is. But the reason he does it is that he knows that if he doesn't, then there will be civil war and so the king issues john the fearless with an official pardon in the spring of 1408 hold on or leon he was the king's what relative was he to the king his brother his
被15名蒙面刺客在他上马时杀害。哇。这是一个转折。刺客被捕了。结果发现负责这些刺客的人是“无畏者”约翰的私人仆人。所以很清楚是谁在背后指使。事实上，“无畏者”约翰并不否认。他委托索邦大学的一位教授发表了一场关于弑君以及它是如何正当的公开演讲。你会认为国王不得不吞下这口气，就像他所做的那样，是一种彻底的羞辱。确实如此。但他这样做的原因是，他知道如果他不这样做，那么就会发生内战，所以国王在1408年春天给了“无畏者”约翰一份官方赦免。等等，奥尔良，他是国王的什么亲戚？他是他的
younger brother he was his brother so his brother has been murdered by 15 masked men yeah and he gives the bloke who did it a pardon just because he's frightened of him. Yeah. Well, that's weak. Well, because not so much that he's worried about John the Fearless, but that he doesn't want France to collapse into civil war. Right. Okay. And John the Fearless, who is incredibly unscrupulous and very, very good at kind of pushing what he can do just far enough, he realises this. And so by November 1408, he's installed himself in Paris as the big man. 1409, he forces the king to issue him another formal pardon in Chartres
弟弟，他是他的弟弟。所以他的弟弟被15名蒙面人谋杀了，是的，他给了那个做这件事的人一份赦免，仅仅是因为他害怕他。是的。嗯，那很软弱。嗯，与其说他担心“无畏者”约翰，不如说他不想让法国陷入内战。没错。好吧。而“无畏者”约翰，他极其肆无忌惮，非常非常擅长把事情推到极限，他意识到了这一点。所以到了1408年11月，他已经在巴黎把自己安顿为大人物。1409年，他强迫国王在沙特尔
Cathedral. And also there in Chartres on that day is the new Duke of Orléans, who's called Charles, who at this point is only 15 years old. And when John the Fearless is given this pardon, it's said that he approaches the young son of the murdered Duke of Orléans, Charles, the new Duke of Orléans, who's only 15 years at this time. So he's had a very, very kind of brutal baptism into being the Duke of Orléans. And he approaches him and he's got tears streaming down his face and he says, I'm sorry, please forgive me. So sorry, I killed your father. Yeah, you know, but let's kiss and make up, you know, water under the bridge, let's move on.
大教堂再次发布了一份正式赦免。那天在沙特尔的还有新的奥尔良公爵，名叫查理，此时他只有15岁。当“无畏者”约翰获得这份赦免时，据说他接近了被谋杀的奥尔良公爵的年轻儿子查理，也就是当时只有15岁的新奥尔良公爵。所以他作为奥尔良公爵经历了一次非常非常残酷的洗礼。他接近他，泪流满面地说，我很抱歉，请原谅我。很抱歉，我杀了你父亲。是的，你知道，但让我们亲吻并和好吧，你知道，过去的事就让它过去吧，让我们继续前进。
And he asks for Orléans' forgiveness and Orléans refuses, even though he's only 15. And the king says, no, you got to kiss and make up. So they do. But I think it's pretty clear that Orléans is biding his time, even though it seems that John is now completely triumphant because he's got the king under his thumb.
他请求奥尔良的原谅，奥尔良拒绝了，尽管他只有15岁。国王说，不，你们必须亲吻并和好。所以他们做了。但我认为很清楚，奥尔良在等待时机，尽管看起来约翰现在完全取得了胜利，因为他把国王控制在手心里。
He's the sole guardian of the Dauphin. He occupies Paris. It all seems brilliant. But the new Duke of Orléans is not taking it lying down. So in 1410, he leaves Paris and he goes to Guienne, which is about 50 miles east of Orléans. He's 16 by now. And he marries a girl called Bon. She's only 11. But that's kind of standard behaviour for this time. Yeah. Bon is the daughter of the Count of Armagnac, who is the Constable of France and very subtle, very skilful kind of little finger from Game of Thrones type character.
他是王太子的唯一监护人。他占领了巴黎。这一切看起来都很棒。但新的奥尔良公爵并没有坐以待毙。所以1410年，他离开巴黎前往吉耶讷，距离奥尔良约50英里。他现在16岁了。他娶了一个叫邦的女孩。她只有11岁。但这在当时是标准行为。是的。邦是阿马尼亚克伯爵的女儿，他是法国的警卫官，是一个非常微妙、非常熟练的《权力的游戏》中“小指头”类型的人物。
A shrewd operator. And so Armagnac has invited, as well as the young Duke of Orléans, he's invited various other Dukes, various other counts to attend the wedding because it's an ideal opportunity for them all to sign up to a kind of anti-Burgundian alliance. And there is one other figure, as well as Orléans, the young Duke of Orléans and Armagnac, And this is the Count of Alençon, who is a great landholder in Normandy. And he is, I mean, he's an absolute bruiser. He's very bold. He's very aggressive. He's kind of compared to a raging boar. And it's said of him by a contemporary chronicler that without Alençon, the good and holy cause of Orléans could not have been sustained. So with
一个精明的经营者。所以阿马尼亚克邀请了年轻的奥尔良公爵，以及其他各种公爵、各种伯爵参加婚礼，因为这对他们所有人来说都是一个签署反勃艮第联盟的理想机会。除了奥尔良，年轻的奥尔良公爵和阿马尼亚克之外，还有另一个人，这就是阿朗松伯爵，他是诺曼底的一位大土地所有者。而且他，我的意思是，他是一个绝对的打手。他非常大胆。他非常有侵略性。他有点像一头狂暴的野猪。一位当代编年史家这样评价他：没有阿朗松，奥尔良那正义而神圣的事业就不可能维持下去。所以有了
this body of very heavyweight allies now behind him, Orléans could not have been sustained. So with this body of very heavyweight allies now behind him, Orléans starts preparing for revenge. And Burgundy is warned about this, so he starts recruiting troops. And it's said that there are so many soldiers out and about that people in France assume that there's an English invasion coming. So the two sides, Orléans, the young teenager who's lost his father and his wife, and their hangers-on, and all these cronies that went to the wedding, and they're the Armagnacs. Yes, because of the Count of Armagnac. And the other side, you have the Burgundians. But crucially, the Burgundians have under their power the king and the dauphin, so they can paint
这群非常有分量的盟友支持他，奥尔良的事业就不可能维持下去。所以有了这群非常有分量的盟友支持他，奥尔良开始准备复仇。勃艮第对此得到了警告，所以他开始招募军队。据说外面有太多的士兵，以至于法国人认为英国的入侵即将来临。所以双方，奥尔良，那个失去了父亲和妻子的年轻少年，以及他们的追随者，还有所有去参加婚礼的亲信，他们就是阿马尼亚克派。是的，因为阿马尼亚克伯爵。而另一边，你有勃艮第派。但关键是，勃艮第派掌握着国王和王太子，所以他们可以把
the Armagnacs as insurgents, as rebels, basically. Exactly. And this is obviously brilliant for England and for Henry IV, who's been having a rough time of it. But it means that he can kind of fish in troubled waters because both sides are appealing to him for assistance. So what Henry does, he sends two expeditions to France. He sends one in 1411 on the side of Burgundy and against the Armagnacs. And then he sends one in 1412 against the Burgundians and on the side of the Armagnacs. Brilliant. That's excellent diplomacy. Yeah. And basically he's doing that because both sides are, you know, they're offering him enormous bribes. They're offering him all kinds of things. And so he plays them off against each other.
阿马尼亚克派描绘成叛乱分子，基本上是叛军。没错。这显然对英国和亨利四世来说非常棒，他一直过得很艰难。但这意味着他可以在浑水中摸鱼，因为双方都在向他寻求援助。所以亨利所做的是，他向法国派遣了两支远征队。他在1411年派遣了一支支持勃艮第、反对阿马尼亚克派的远征队。然后在1412年派遣了一支反对勃艮第、支持阿马尼亚克派的远征队。太棒了。那是出色的外交。是的。基本上他这样做是因为双方都在，你知道，他们都在向他提供巨大的贿赂。他们都在向他提供各种各样的东西。所以他让他们互相争斗。
And actually he ends up basically being promised the whole of the Duchy of Aquitaine, which was the lands that were the kind of ancestral fiefdom of the kings of England and which Edward III had aggrandized. He'd been given an enormous tranche and the French had then whittled away. So, you know, this is looking great for Henry IV. And you'd think also that it would be the perfect opportunity for Henry to blood his eldest son, the Prince of Wales, the future Henry V. But interestingly, he doesn't. And this may well reflect the fact that, as we talked about in the previous episode, relations between father and eldest son by this point seem to have become quite troubled. But what Henry does,
事实上，他最终基本上被承诺了整个阿基坦公国，这是作为英国国王祖传封地的土地，也是爱德华三世曾经扩张过的土地。他被给予了巨大的一块，而法国人随后将其削减了。所以，你知道，这对亨利四世来说看起来很棒。你也会认为这对亨利来说是让他的长子，威尔士亲王，未来的亨利五世见血的绝佳机会。但有趣的是，他没有。这很可能反映了这样一个事实，正如我们在上一集中谈到的，父亲和长子之间的关系到这个时候似乎已经变得相当麻烦。但亨利所做的是，
he sends two people, both of whom are very close friends of Henry. Both of them are called Thomas, I'm pleased to say. So the first of them, the one who goes in 1411 is the Earl of Arundel, who had served with the Prince of Wales in Wales, one of his closest friends. And the second is the eldest of his three younger brothers, Thomas the Duke of Clarence. And for Clarence, it's very, very annoying because he arrives in France at the head of this great expedition, only to find that the two sides have made up again. So they've signed a compact. And Orléans is incredibly apologetic, says, you know, I'm really sorry, you won't have a chance to go out and sort of loot and stuff. But he gives Clarence a massive payoff. The two men become sworn brothers in arms and Clarence swears a formal oath that he will serve, aid, console and comfort Orléans. And he then goes back to England and he's loaded down with booty.
他派了两个人，他们都是亨利的密友。我很高兴地说，他们都叫托马斯。所以他们中的第一个，1411年去的那个人是阿伦德尔伯爵，他曾在威尔士与威尔士亲王一起服役，是他最亲密的朋友之一。第二个是他三个弟弟中的长子，克拉伦斯公爵托马斯。对于克拉伦斯来说，这非常非常令人恼火，因为他率领这支伟大的远征队抵达法国，却发现双方又和好了。所以他们签署了一份契约。奥尔良非常抱歉，说，你知道，我真的很抱歉，你没有机会出去抢劫什么的。但他给了克拉伦斯一笔巨大的报酬。两人成为了宣誓的战友，克拉伦斯发了一个正式誓言，他将服务、援助、安慰和慰藉奥尔良。然后他回到英国，满载着战利品。
Even though he hasn't fought a single battle, he hasn't captured a single town. And it's a reminder to the English court of just how many riches are on offer in France. And so when Henry V comes to the throne, he's all the more alert than he would have been anyway to the opportunities on offer. And he can see in the loot that Clarence has brought back that the civil war in France absolutely promises an opportunity to win not just booty, but possibly land as well. Yeah. So it's that classic thing of a great sort of continental power that is riven by internal tension and a kind of offshore, smaller power that sees the opportunity to basically carve out. So it's a little bit kind of Japan and China in the 20th century or something. Well, the problem for France
即使他没有打过一场战斗，他没有占领过一个城镇。这提醒了英国宫廷，法国提供了多少财富。所以当亨利五世登上王位时，他比以往任何时候都更加警惕所提供的机会。他可以在克拉伦斯带回的战利品中看到，法国的内战绝对承诺了一个不仅能赢得战利品，而且可能赢得土地的机会。是的。所以这是一种经典的模式，一个巨大的大陆强国被内部紧张局势所撕裂，而一个离岸的、较小的强国看到了基本上进行瓜分的机会。所以这有点像20世纪的日本和中国之类的。好吧，法国的问题
is that Henry's crowned on the 9th of April, 1413. There's a kind of unseasonal snowstorm and contemporaries are unclear whether this is a good or bad omen. But what is very clear is that the new king is very, very formidable. So he's 26 by this point. He's battle-hardened. He's skilled in all the practicalities of kingship because he's effectively been ruling for long stretches of his father's reign. He's a man of absolutely iron determination, extraordinary capabilities. So in every way, if there is a man who is qualified to exploit the divisions in France, it is the new king of England. Well, that's good to hear. That's very promising. And it bodes well for the second half of this episode, in which we will discover if Henry V is indeed the man to profit from the internal
是亨利在1413年4月9日加冕。当时有一场反季节的暴风雪，同时代的人不清楚这到底是好兆头还是坏兆头。但非常清楚的是，这位新国王非常非常可怕。所以他此时26岁。他久经沙场。他精通统治的所有实际操作，因为他在他父亲统治的大部分时间里实际上一直在统治。他是一个绝对意志坚定、能力非凡的人。所以无论从哪个方面来看，如果有一个人有资格利用法国的分裂，那就是英国的新国王。好吧，听到这个很高兴。这非常有希望。这预示着本集节目的后半部分，我们将发现亨利五世是否确实是那个能从内部
divisions of France. Come back we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com We are glad that Dauphin is so pleasant with us. His present and your pains we thank you for. When we have matched our rackets to these balls,
分裂中获利的人。回来吧，我们主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com 我们很高兴王太子对我们如此友好。感谢他的礼物和您的辛劳。当我们把球拍和这些球匹配好后，
we will in France, by God's grace, play a set, shall strike his father's crown into the hazard. So that's one of the most famous episodes in Shakespeare's play, Henry V. It's an episode that I remember very well from the Lady Bird book about Henry V that I read as a little boy. Yes, great illustration of it. So Henry V is sent to an embassy to France to basically demand his ancestral rights. And the Dauphin replies to him by sending him this, in the Ladybug book, there's a huge sort of chest full of tennis balls and they're all kind of, they're all bouncing all over the court.
我们将在法国，靠上帝的恩典，打一场比赛，将他父亲的王冠击入险境。所以这是莎士比亚戏剧《亨利五世》中最著名的片段之一。这是一个我从小时候读的关于亨利五世的瓢虫书（Lady Bird book）中记得非常清楚的片段。是的，有很棒的插图。所以亨利五世被派往法国大使馆，基本上是为了要求他的祖传权利。而王太子通过给他发送这个回复，在瓢虫书中，有一个巨大的装满网球的箱子，它们都在球场上弹来弹去。
And Henry says in the play, his jest will savour but of shallow wit when thousands weep more than did laugh at it. In other words, basically the Dauphin has said, this is, you know, why don't you play tennis and shut up and forget about interfering with France? And Henry's very offended by this and is like, you won't be laughing when we turn up with our rackets
亨利在剧中说，他的玩笑只会显得浅薄，当成千上万的人哭泣时，比笑的人多得多。换句话说，基本上王太子说，这是，你知道，你为什么不打网球闭嘴，忘了干涉法国呢？亨利对此非常反感，就像，当我们带着我们的球拍出现时，你不会笑的
and we will play such a set that men will, you know, or something like that. I've just invented that. It always makes me think of Obama laughing at Trump. Right. At that, whatever it is, they hold the big thing for journalists yeah the thing with the journalists presidents make terrible jokes and journalists pretend to find them amusing yeah and uh trump glowering and then goes off and kind of does a henry v so i mean the obvious question did it actually happen so anne curry who is as well as being a herald, is also the great doyen of Agincourt's studies.
我们将打这样一场比赛，人们会，你知道，或者类似的话。我刚才编造了那个。它总是让我想起奥巴马嘲笑特朗普。没错。在那个，无论是什么，他们为记者举办的大型活动，是的，那个有记者的活动，总统开糟糕的玩笑，记者假装觉得它们很有趣，是的，而特朗普怒视着，然后走开，有点像亨利五世。所以我的意思是，显而易见的问题是，它真的发生了吗？所以安·柯里，她不仅是一位纹章官，也是阿金库尔研究的伟大权威。
She's a herald? She's a herald. I think she's the herald of the Earl of Arundel or something. When the Earl of Arundel goes out for dinner or something, does she accompany him in a surcoat, like blowing a trumpet? There's brilliant photographs of her in a kind of herald outfit. Wow. Yeah, so check them out. So she's very sceptical. She says the whole story is easily dismissed. But I'm pleased to say that Christopher Ormond, who's the great biographer of Henry V, he is slightly less sceptical.
她是纹章官？她是纹章官。我想她是阿伦德尔伯爵的纹章官之类的。当阿伦德尔伯爵出去吃饭时，她会穿着外套陪同他，像吹小号一样吗？有她穿着纹章官服装的精彩照片。哇。是的，所以去看看吧。所以她非常怀疑。她说整个故事很容易被驳回。但我很高兴地说，克里斯托弗·奥尔曼，他是亨利五世的伟大传记作者，他稍微没那么怀疑。
And he cites an Englishman who's gone on an embassy to Paris and is told by one of the Frenchmen opposite that they view Henry with utter contempt and his ambitions. And that they're going to send him balls with which to play with and cushions upon which to lie. And the implication is that essentially the king is a baby. This is all ridiculous talk. and that they're going to send him balls with which to play with and cushions upon which to lie. And the implication is that essentially the king is a baby. You know, this is all ridiculous talk. And so Allman says, perhaps this is what kind of gave rise to the story. And also, of course, it reflects the character of the Dauphin. It's the kind of thing that perhaps that he would do.
他引用了一位去巴黎出使的英国人的话，对面的法国人告诉他，他们对亨利和他的野心表示极度的蔑视。他们要送给他球来玩，还有垫子让他躺在上面。暗示基本上国王是个婴儿。这都是荒谬的谈话。他们要送给他球来玩，还有垫子让他躺在上面。暗示基本上国王是个婴儿。你知道，这都是荒谬的谈话。所以奥尔曼说，也许这就是导致这个故事的原因。而且当然，它反映了王太子的性格。这可能是他会做的那种事情。
But what it also does, it absolutely exemplifies the state of Anglo-French relations in the first two years of Henry V's reign, because essentially the story of these years is Henry sending embassies to Paris or to Burgundy to try and negotiate alliances or to extort lands and titles from the French king, and the French refusing to play ball. So among the ambassadors who go is the son of Geoffrey Chaucer, Thomas Chaucer, who is a member of parliament, speaker for three times. And he's going off to Burgundy. Others are going to Paris. And they're demanding, first of all, a daughter of John the Fearless for Henry, then Catherine, the daughter of Charles VI. They want all the lands that Edward III had been promised. And also they'd quite like the Duchy of Normandy, perhaps, and perhaps the throne of France. It's unclear exactly what, but basically they want
但它同时也完美地体现了亨利五世统治头两年英法关系的现状，因为这些年故事的核心本质上就是亨利不断派遣使团前往巴黎或勃艮第，试图协商结盟，或者勒索法国国王的土地和头衔，而法国人则拒绝配合。因此，出使的使节中包括杰弗里·乔叟的儿子托马斯·乔叟，他曾是议会议员，并三次担任议长。他前往勃艮第，其他人则前往巴黎。他们首先要求法国人为亨利迎娶无畏者约翰的女儿，后来又要求迎娶查理六世的女儿凯瑟琳。他们想要爱德华三世曾被许诺的所有土地，还想要诺曼底公国，甚至可能想要法国王位。虽然具体要求尚不明确，但基本上他们想要
lots of things. And also they would like the full ransom that was supposed to have been paid for John, the King of France, who had been captured by the Black Prince at the Battle of Poitiers, and which the French had ended up not paying in its entirety. But do you know what? Henry V is the thing about like, oh, you're untried. You're just a toddler. Here are some tennis balls. You do the ludicrous demands. Henry V is not a person to take lightly.
很多东西。他们还想要当初本应为法国国王约翰支付的全部赎金，约翰在普瓦捷战役中被黑太子俘虏，而法国人最终并没有全额支付。但你知道吗？亨利五世对于那种“哦，你还没经过考验，你只是个蹒跚学步的孩子，给你些网球吧”的嘲讽，以及那些荒谬的要求，他绝不是一个可以被轻视的人。
No, exactly. Because as you said, he's 26 years old. He's battle-hardened. He's clearly a very sort of severe, serious, formidable man. It seems to me bonkers that the Dauphin would have provoked him in this way. And you know, Dominic, there are people in France who are keeping abreast of English affairs who do think Henry V is very impressive, and not just as a soldier, but as a man who essentially he seems to avow celibacy until he gets married. And the contrast there with the Dauphin is very great.
不，确实如此。因为正如你所说，他才26岁，身经百战。他显然是一个非常严厉、严肃且令人敬畏的人。在我看来，王太子以这种方式挑衅他简直是疯了。而且你知道吗，多米尼克，法国国内也有人一直关注着英国的事务，他们认为亨利五世非常令人印象深刻，不仅作为一名士兵，而且作为一个在结婚前似乎誓言保持独身的人。这与王太子形成了巨大的反差。
Oh, really? He devotes himself full-bloodedly to all his responsibilities as king. Again, huge contrast with the Dauphin. So there are people who actually quite admire him and are nervous about this. And I think also what makes it all the stranger, you know, if the tennis ball thing did happen, is that France in this period, so in the years that follow Henry's coronation, is slipping right back into civil war. So there'd
哦，真的吗？他全心全意地投入到作为国王的所有职责中。这再次与王太子形成了巨大的反差。所以确实有人相当钦佩他，并对此感到紧张。而且我认为，如果网球事件真的发生过，让这一切变得更加奇怪的是，法国在这一时期，也就是亨利加冕后的几年里，正滑向内战。所以当时
been that brief compact between the Armagnacs and the Burgundians, which had seen the Duke of Clarence return with all his booty, but it doesn't last. And so in the same year that Henry is crowned, 1413, John the Fearless has been busy recruiting a paramilitary force with which to seize control of Paris. And we're recording this in the wake of the series that we did on the French Revolution. And there are some very weird premonitions of the French Revolution in this story. It's almost like a kind of overture. So the people that John the Fearless is siding with are members of the Butcher's Guild in Paris, who are known as the Écocheurs. The Flayers.
阿马尼亚克派和勃艮第派之间曾有过短暂的协议，克拉伦斯公爵带着所有战利品回国了，但这并没有持续多久。就在亨利加冕的同一年，即1413年，无畏者约翰一直忙于招募一支准军事部队，企图夺取巴黎的控制权。我们是在录制完法国大革命系列节目后录制这一期的，这个故事中确实有一些非常诡异的法国大革命预兆。这几乎就像是一种序曲。无畏者约翰所支持的人是巴黎屠夫行会的成员，他们被称为“剥皮者”（Écocheurs）。
The Flayers, yes. Or they're alternatively known as the Cabochiens after their leader, Simon Caboch. And they wear very distinctive white hoods. And it's a bit like the Liberty cap. They basically go around forcing their superiors to wear these caps as a way of kind of humbling them. So they force them on noblemans, they force them on clerics and bishops, and they even force them on the Queen's ladies of honour. And they commission investigators to go around the city, finding out people whose hearts are not fully with them, who are not engaged with this kind of revolution that they're trying to instill. And then the names of those who are not on the side of the cabochier are proclaimed at street corners. So there is a kind of slight 1791 quality to all this, except that they are not targeting the king and there are
“剥皮者”，是的。或者他们也被称为“卡博什派”（Cabochiens），以他们的领袖西蒙·卡博什命名。他们戴着非常有特色的白色兜帽。这有点像自由帽。他们基本上到处强迫上层人士戴上这些帽子，以此作为一种羞辱他们的方式。所以他们强迫贵族戴上，强迫教士和主教戴上，甚至强迫王后的女官们戴上。他们还委派调查员在城里四处搜寻那些心不完全向着他们、没有参与他们试图灌输的这种革命的人。然后，那些不支持卡博什派的人的名字会在街头巷尾被宣读。所以这一切确实带有一点1791年的色彩，只不过他们并没有针对国王，而且
opportunities for John the Fearless to exploit them. And that's what he's doing because basically he's using them to intimidate the Dauphin. And at the beginning of May 1413, the Cabochin invade the Dauphin's palace. They've brought in a white hood. They make the Dauphin wear it. And the Cabochin kind of give him a stern lecture, say, you're rubbish. You know, you need to pull your socks up. They bring in clerics who give the poor Dauphin kind of lots of sermons, tell him to pull his socks up. And they also attack and eliminate a lot of the Dauphin's particular allies. So Anne Currie, in her absolutely groundbreaking book on Agincourt, she says that their assaults included the public beheading of the corpse of the Dauphin's Chamberlain, who had allegedly committed suicide in prison by hitting his head repeatedly with a wine jug.
无畏者约翰有机会利用他们。他正是这么做的，因为他基本上是在利用他们来恐吓王太子。1413年5月初，卡博什派入侵了王太子的宫殿。他们带进了一个白色兜帽，强迫王太子戴上。卡博什派对他进行了一番严厉的训斥，说：“你太差劲了。你需要振作起来。”他们带进教士，对可怜的王太子进行了一番说教，告诉他要振作起来。他们还攻击并消灭了许多王太子的亲信。所以安·柯里在她那本关于阿金库尔战役的开创性著作中说，他们的袭击包括公开斩首王太子侍从长的尸体，此人据称在狱中用酒壶反复击打头部自杀身亡。
I saw that and I was sceptical. Would that work? If you just hit yourself again and again with a jug? I don't think that would work. No, of course not. It's a deliberate way of saying, you know, we're not admitting to the murder, but basically we will murder you. So he was definitely killed by these white hooded cabochers. Yeah, of course.
我看到了这一点，但我很怀疑。这行得通吗？如果你反复用酒壶击打自己？我不认为这行得通。不，当然不行。这是一种蓄意的说法，意思是：“你知道，我们不承认谋杀，但基本上我们会杀了你。”所以他绝对是被这些戴着白色兜帽的卡博什派杀害的。是的，当然。
Okay. The flayers. This is very Game of Thrones territory here. Yes, it is. Yes, and maybe not coincidentally. I mean, I think all this period is kind of huge influence on the writing of Game of Thrones.
好的。“剥皮者”。这非常有《权力的游戏》的氛围。是的，确实。而且也许并非巧合。我的意思是，我认为整个这一时期对《权力的游戏》的创作有着巨大的影响。
Yeah. And so the poor Dauphin ends up basically a kind of prisoner. The king all this while has been, you know, he's been out with his mental problems. Then he recovers from them. He goes in a state procession to Notre Dame to give thanks. And the Cabochia ambush him and inevitably they've got a white hood and they make the king wear it and the king puts it on. So very bad. And the king and the Dauphin between them think, well, this is terrible. You know, we need to sort this out.
是的。所以可怜的王太子最终基本上成了一个囚犯。与此同时，国王一直有精神问题。后来他康复了，去巴黎圣母院进行国事游行以示感谢。卡博什派伏击了他，不出所料，他们拿出了一个白色兜帽，强迫国王戴上，国王戴上了。这太糟糕了。国王和王太子两人都认为，这太可怕了。我们需要解决这个问题。
And so they turn to the Armagnacs who are lurking off in Orléans. And most of the Armagnacs are too nervous to intervene because they're afraid of the Cabochins. They're, you know, they're very, very menacing. Oh, really? But there is the Count of Alençon, who you may remember we described as this kind of fearless, bold, boar-like man. A bruiser, you said he was.
于是他们转向了潜伏在奥尔良的阿马尼亚克派。大多数阿马尼亚克派因为害怕卡博什派而不敢干预。他们非常、非常具有威胁性。哦，真的吗？但阿朗松伯爵在那里，你可能还记得我们形容他是一个无畏、大胆、像野猪一样的人。你说他是个打手。
A bruiser. And he's not going to be intimidated by a bunch of butchers. So he raises a force, coordinates an attack on Paris. And on the 4th of August, 1413, the Armagnacs break into Paris and they massacre the Cabochins, who prove unable to deal with armed knights who have burst into the city. John the Fearless, all his plans are falling to pieces. He tries to kidnap the king. That's frustrated. He then scarpers. And of course, this is brilliant for the Armagnacs. They've now got Paris. They've got the king, but it's still not brilliant for the
一个打手。他不会被一群屠夫吓倒。所以他集结了一支部队，协调了对巴黎的进攻。1413年8月4日，阿马尼亚克派冲进巴黎，屠杀了卡博什派，他们证明自己无法应对冲进城市的武装骑士。无畏者约翰的所有计划都破灭了。他试图绑架国王，但失败了。然后他逃跑了。当然，这对阿马尼亚克派来说太棒了。他们现在占领了巴黎，控制了国王，但这对于
Dauphin because now he's replaced the Burgundians with the Armagnacs and they're still kind of kicking him around. Basically, he wants to be the big man, he wants to be in charge, but it's always either the Burgundians or the Armagnacs. And the Dauphin and the king remain essentially ciphers. And so instead of a return to a secure monarchy, there's a collapse back into civil war. John the Fearless is banished from France as a traitor. The Armagnacs march into Burgundian territories. They attack the town of Soissons, which is a Burgundian town. They storm it and they inflict a brutal, notorious storm on it. The town is wasted. Nuns are raped, all that kind of thing. So while all this is going on, presumably Henry V is in
王太子来说仍然不是什么好事，因为现在他用阿马尼亚克派取代了勃艮第派，而他们仍然在欺负他。基本上，他想成为大人物，他想掌权，但总是要么是勃艮第派，要么是阿马尼亚克派。王太子和国王本质上仍然是傀儡。因此，并没有回归到一个稳固的君主制，而是重新陷入了内战。无畏者约翰作为叛徒被逐出法国。阿马尼亚克派开进勃艮第领地。他们袭击了苏瓦松镇，这是一个勃艮第城镇。他们攻占了它，并对它进行了残酷、臭名昭著的洗劫。城镇被毁，修女被强奸，诸如此类。所以当这一切发生时，亨利五世大概正在
England and he's watching all this and he must be thinking, as France slips further and further into chaos, this is my opportunity. I mean, this is the prize waiting for the plucking. He does absolutely think that. And so he starts sending renewed embassies to John the Fearless saying, you know, come on, let's have an alliance. Let's go and, you know, attack Paris and the Armagnacs together. But John the Fearless is also a very shrewd political player. And so he uses the threat of an English alliance essentially to kind of force a peace on the Armagnacs. And so they sign yet another compact. And this is very bad news for Henry because suddenly, you know, he no longer has a potential alliance with the Burgundians. And Henry's ambassadors, who are actually in Paris when this Armagnac-Burgundian peace is
英国，他看着这一切，一定在想，随着法国越来越陷入混乱，这是我的机会。我的意思是，这是等待采摘的奖品。他绝对是这么想的。于是他开始向无畏者约翰派遣新的使团，说：“来吧，让我们结盟吧。让我们一起去攻击巴黎和阿马尼亚克派。”但无畏者约翰也是一个非常精明的政治玩家。所以他利用英法结盟的威胁，基本上强迫阿马尼亚克派求和。于是他们又签署了一份协议。这对亨利来说是个坏消息，因为突然间，他不再有与勃艮第派结盟的可能。而亨利的使节，当这份阿马尼亚克-勃艮第和平协议在巴黎
announced, realise that the ground has been completely cut from under their feet. They leave Paris empty-handed. They travel back, Dominic, to the Normandy coast and they take ship for England from the port of Harfleur. And they're back by the end of March 1415 with nothing to show for their diplomatic efforts, seemingly humiliated. But Henry, he's not bothered about that, right? Because he has already made his mind up that actually, you know, he'll never get a better opportunity
宣布时，他们就在巴黎，意识到他们的立足点完全被抽走了。他们空手离开了巴黎。多米尼克，他们回到诺曼底海岸，从哈弗勒尔港乘船前往英国。他们在1415年3月底回到英国，外交努力一无所获，看起来受到了羞辱。但亨利并不在意，对吧？因为他已经下定决心，实际上，他永远不会有更好的机会
to carve out more lands, also to improve his reputation. You know, there are all kinds of reasons pushing him in favour of a French war, aren't there? Yeah. And so he's basically decided since the beginning of 1415 that he is going to go to war no matter what happens in Paris. So at the end of January, he dissembled representatives from all the kind of the main ports and harbours of southern England to tell them, I need ships, you know, provide me with ships. He'd start putting out feelers to Hanseatic ports along the coast of Northern Europe. 20th of February, he has sent out summons
去开辟更多的土地，也能提升他的声誉。你知道，有很多原因促使他支持对法战争，不是吗？是的。所以他基本上从1415年初就决定，无论巴黎发生什么，他都要开战。所以在1月底，他召集了英格兰南部所有主要港口和海港的代表，告诉他们：“我需要船只，为我提供船只。”他开始向北欧沿海的汉萨同盟港口试探。2月20日，他发出了传唤
to a great council of all the peers of England, which is due to meet on the 15th of April. And now, just before that meeting, his ambassadors come back from Paris, seemingly humiliated. And so he can demonstrate to the English and to the whole of Christendom that he's tried, he's made efforts, and his peace-loving efforts have been rebuffed. So that's why the tennis ball story works. It does. Because the tennis ball story, I mean, it can stand in for him saying, look, I've asked, I've asked nicely, I've pursued the path of diplomacy, and it has failed.
给英格兰所有的贵族召开大议会，定于4月15日举行。现在，就在会议之前，他的使节从巴黎回来，看起来受到了羞辱。所以他可以向英国和整个基督教世界证明，他已经尝试过了，他已经做出了努力，但他热爱和平的努力遭到了拒绝。这就是为什么网球的故事行得通。确实。因为网球的故事，我的意思是，它可以代表他说：“看，我问过了，我客气地问过了，我追求了外交途径，但失败了。”
They've been thrown back in my face. I have no alternative now but to take military action. Because the mockery of Henry is the mockery of England. And so everyone in England, and including Parliament crucially, which votes money, can now be expected to rally behind him. So it's an absolutely classic example of Henry's genius, which he demonstrates throughout his life. He can turn seeming rebuffs, seeming setbacks, seeming disasters to his own advantage. And he will do this throughout his forthcoming invasion of France. But I guess it does focus one obvious question that people listening may have been wondering, which is apart from expediency, apart from the opportunity that the civil war in France
他们把这些扔回了我的脸上。我现在别无选择，只能采取军事行动。因为对亨利的嘲弄就是对英国的嘲弄。所以英国的每个人，包括至关重要的议会（议会负责投票拨款），现在都可以被期待团结在他身后。所以这是一个亨利天才的绝对经典例子，他在一生中都展现了这一点。他可以将看似拒绝、看似挫折、看似灾难的事情转化为自己的优势。他将在即将到来的入侵法国的过程中一直这样做。但我猜这确实引出了一个听众可能一直在想的明显问题，那就是除了权宜之计，除了法国内战提供的机会，
offers him, are there other motives he has for going to war? And I think indisputably, he authentically and genuinely believes that God does want him to be king. So it's quote Jonathan Sumption, who's written this absolutely enormous history of the Hundred Years' War in Cursed Kings, his book on this period. Assumption writes, Henry constantly presented his claims against the French as an appeal to God against the wickedness and unworthiness of England's traditional enemy. And Assumption goes on to say, this is not humbug. Henry is a ferociously devout and orthodox king, and he absolutely believes it. He genuinely thinks he has a right to be the king of France. And that goes back to Edward III.
他发动战争还有其他动机吗？我认为毫无疑问，他真实且真诚地相信上帝确实希望他成为国王。引用乔纳森·萨姆普申的话，他在《被诅咒的国王》中写了这部关于百年战争的极其宏大的历史，他在书中写道，亨利不断地将他针对法国人的主张表现为向上帝申诉，反对英国传统敌人的邪恶和不配。萨姆普申继续说，这不是骗人的。亨利是一位极其虔诚和正统的国王，他绝对相信这一点。他真诚地认为他有权成为法国国王。这可以追溯到爱德华三世。
And he thinks this isn't just propaganda. It's not contrivance. It's not an excuse. It's real. I should be the king of France, and God wants me to be the king of France. I think his readiness to invade France shows that he does think that, because effectively for Henry, devout that he is, by invading France, he is putting himself to the test. And if he fails, then it will demonstrate that God is not on his side. If he succeeds,
他认为这不仅仅是宣传。这不是虚构。这不是借口。这是真实的。我应该是法国国王，上帝希望我成为法国国王。我认为他入侵法国的准备工作表明他确实是这样想的，因为对于亨利来说，他如此虔诚，通过入侵法国，他是在考验自己。如果他失败了，那么这将证明上帝不在他这一边。如果他成功了，
then it will demonstrate that God is on his side. But Tom, more prosaically, if he invades France, if he gets Parliament to vote in money, he invades France, it goes horribly wrong. He could be killed, he could be taken prisoner, but also it could shatter his legitimacy back at home, right? I mean, listeners won't have forgotten, his father was a usurper. Yeah, absolutely. So in a sense, he's a usurper himself, you could argue, or at least is the beneficiary of a usurpation. And so his legitimacy is more precious and also more fragile than it would be if he were
那么这将证明上帝站在他这一边。但是汤姆，更平庸地说，如果他入侵法国，如果他让议会投票拨款，他入侵法国，结果却出了大乱子。他可能会被杀，可能会被俘，但这也会摧毁他在国内的合法性，对吧？我的意思是，听众不会忘记，他的父亲是一个篡位者。是的，绝对。所以从某种意义上说，你可以说他自己也是一个篡位者，或者至少是篡位的受益者。所以他的合法性比他如果是
a different king. Well, I think this is a further dimension because it is often the way of the very devout that they tend to devoutly believe things that they need to believe. And this idea that Henry V, who is the son of a usurper, might be able to consolidate his regime and rally his people behind him is summed up in a phrase that Shakespeare uses in Henry IV, where the dying king is talking to his son and offering him his advice for how he should rule. And he says, busy giddy minds with foreign quarrels. In other words, take the minds of people in England off rebellion against you, off insurrection, and channel those energies into war with France.
一个不同的国王要珍贵得多，也脆弱得多。嗯，我认为这是一个更深层的维度，因为虔诚的人往往倾向于虔诚地相信他们需要相信的事情。而这个想法，即身为篡位者之子的亨利五世，可能能够巩固他的政权并团结他的人民，在莎士比亚在《亨利四世》中使用的一句话中得到了总结，当时垂死的国王正在与他的儿子交谈，并为他应该如何统治提供建议。他说：“用对外争端来忙碌那些轻浮的头脑。”换句话说，让英国人民的注意力从反抗你、从叛乱中转移开，并将这些能量引导到与法国的战争中。
And Henry is undoubtedly very, very aware of the fact that he's the son of a usurper. So Henry IV had buried Richard II's body, not in Westminster Abbey in the great tomb that Richard II had prepared for himself. But Henry V has Richard II's body translated to that tomb. And I think that that reflects the fact, again, that Henry V is a great believer in the sanctity of himself as an anointed king. And so he genuinely believes in the sanctity of Richard II as well. So there are all kinds of complicated motives. But I do agree, Henry is laying things on the line because essentially, if he fails, it will not only prove that God is not on his side, but it may well shatter his reign and
亨利无疑非常、非常清楚他是篡位者之子的事实。所以亨利四世埋葬了理查二世的尸体，不是在威斯敏斯特教堂理查二世为自己准备的宏伟陵墓中。但亨利五世将理查二世的尸体移到了那个陵墓中。我认为这反映了一个事实，即亨利五世非常相信自己作为受膏国王的神圣性。所以他也真诚地相信理查二世的神圣性。所以有各种复杂的动机。但我确实同意，亨利是在孤注一掷，因为本质上，如果他失败了，这不仅会证明上帝不在他这一边，而且很可能会彻底摧毁他的统治和
the whole legitimacy of the Lancastrian dynasty for good. So the stakes are absolutely enormous. But I think he's relying on God's backing for him, but he's also relying on the fact that France is in chaos and that he himself as king is a seasoned leader and that he is qualified absolutely to lead an invasion. He's only been king for two years. There's only two years, aren't there, between him becoming king and Agincourt? Yeah. Why the urgency? I mean, he's 26. He could be king for another quarter of a century, if not longer. So why does he feel... Of course, France is a bit of a basket case right now.
整个兰开斯特王朝的合法性。所以赌注绝对是巨大的。但我认为他依靠上帝对他的支持，但他也依靠法国处于混乱之中，以及他自己作为国王是一位经验丰富的领导者，他绝对有资格领导入侵。他才当了两年国王。从他成为国王到阿金库尔战役，只有两年时间，不是吗？是的。为什么要这么急？我的意思是，他才26岁。如果不是更久的话，他还可以再当四分之一个世纪的国王。所以他为什么觉得……当然，法国现在有点像个烂摊子。
But do you think that speaks to a deep insecurity that he feels he has to prove himself quickly? I mean, to put it all on the line straight away when you're 26 years old? I think that is part of it. But I think above all, he just feels, you know, he's going to be good at it. He's going to do it. And you will know, because we've discussed this, that I once nominated Henry V as the most overrated king in English history, because I thought that launching an invasion of France, that it was doomed ultimately to failure, that it was a waste of resources, that it was a kind of ultimately an immoral thing to do. Having gone deep into this, I've now slightly changed my mind on that. I still think that it was, you know, it proves to be a terrible waste of money and resources and inflicts devastation on large numbers of people, you know, horrific for France. But I think to blame Henry for doing it is kind of akin to
但你认为这是否说明了一种深层的不安全感，即他觉得必须尽快证明自己？我的意思是，当你26岁时，立刻把一切都押上？我认为这是其中的一部分。但我认为最重要的是，他只是觉得，你知道，他会擅长这件事。他会做到的。而且你会知道，因为我们讨论过这个，我曾经提名亨利五世为英国历史上最被高估的国王，因为我认为发动对法国的入侵，最终注定会失败，那是资源的浪费，那是一种最终不道德的行为。深入研究之后，我现在对此稍微改变了主意。我仍然认为，你知道，事实证明这是对金钱和资源的巨大浪费，并给大量人口造成了破坏，你知道，对法国来说是可怕的。但我认为责怪亨利这样做，有点类似于
blaming, I don't know, a lion for eating a zebra. It's just what he's going to do. He is a great king. He's a formidable military operator. He has the opportunity. He thinks God is on his side. Why wait? Let's crack on. Brilliant. Love it. And Henry can be confident that he'll be successful because he can trust not just in his own abilities, but he also, I mean, he's very much on top of all the other advantages he has. So, I mean, just to look at them, he has hugely experienced lieutenants. So he has his three brothers. So he's got Clarence, who's already been on an expedition. He's got his younger brother, Humphrey, the Duke of Gloucester, who will be going with him on the expedition and being kind of bloodied on this campaign. He's going to leave his middle brother, John, the
责怪，我不知道，狮子吃斑马。这只是他要做的事。他是一位伟大的国王。他是一位强大的军事指挥官。他有机会。他认为上帝站在他这一边。为什么要等？让我们开始吧。太棒了。喜欢它。亨利可以确信他会成功，因为他不仅可以相信自己的能力，而且，我的意思是，他非常清楚他拥有的所有其他优势。所以，我的意思是，看看它们，他有经验极其丰富的副手。所以他有他的三个兄弟。所以他有克拉伦斯，他已经参加过一次远征了。他有他的弟弟，格洛斯特公爵汉弗莱，他将和他一起参加远征，并在这次战役中经受洗礼。他将把他的二弟，约翰，
Duke of Bedford behind. Very competent, very loyal again. So Henry can be sure that England is secure in his rear. He's got his broader family. So notably Edward, the Duke of York, his cousin, who will be a kind of prominent leader on the campaign that's coming up. He's got his friends. He's got the Earl of Arundel, who led the campaign in 1411. And he's the bloke who's got Anne Currie, the historian as his herald. Is that right? Yeah, exactly. It all interweaves. So Henry's got Arundel and he's got all the rest of the peers. And basically all the peers will be coming with him. Henry's expecting that. But they want to go. I mean, Henry is giving them
贝德福德公爵留在后面。非常能干，也非常忠诚。所以亨利可以确信英国在他的后方是安全的。他有他的大家族。所以值得注意的是爱德华，约克公爵，他的堂兄，他将成为即将到来的战役中的一位杰出领导者。他有他的朋友。他有阿伦德尔伯爵，他领导了1411年的战役。他就是那个让历史学家安·柯里担任他传令官的人，对吧？是的，完全正确。这一切都交织在一起。所以亨利有阿伦德尔，他还有其他所有的贵族。基本上所有的贵族都会和他一起去。亨利期待着这一点。但他们想去。我的意思是，亨利正在给他们
what Edward III had given them and which Richard II hadn't, which is an opportunity for loot and glory and basically fun. So they're all lined up behind him. Unlike the French nobles who are all busy attacking each other, the English nobles, they're ready to go. And of course, Henry has, as he well knows, because he ended up with an arrow as a young man sticking in his skull. He has the most lethal killing machine in Europe, massive contingents of longbowmen. And just to remind people of what that means, these are arrows that can be fired with great accuracy, over 200 meters. A trained longbowman can fire kind of like 15 arrows a minute. Henry's taking about 7,000 archers to France. So 7,000 archers, they could fire what kind of over a hundred thousand arrows in a minute.
爱德华三世给过他们的，而理查二世没有给过的东西，那就是掠夺、荣耀和基本上乐趣的机会。所以他们都排在他身后。与忙于互相攻击的法国贵族不同，英国贵族，他们准备出发了。当然，亨利知道，因为他年轻时曾被一支箭射中头骨，他拥有欧洲最致命的杀戮机器，大量的长弓手。为了提醒人们这意味着什么，这些箭可以在200米外以极高的精度射出。一名训练有素的长弓手一分钟可以射出大约15支箭。亨利带了大约7000名弓箭手去法国。所以7000名弓箭手，他们一分钟可以射出超过十万支箭。
Wow. Collectively. I mean, that's a devastating firestorm. Henry knows what this is like. He suffered it. He's experienced it. And these archers, some of them are coming from Cheshire. You know, Henry Vaziel of Chester is the Prince of Wales. He knows how good they are. There are archers from Wales as well, also from Lancashire. These are the best in the country and therefore in the whole of Christendom. Yeah.
哇。集体来说。我的意思是，那是一场毁灭性的火风暴。亨利知道这是什么感觉。他遭受过。他经历过。这些弓箭手，他们中的一些来自柴郡。你知道，亨利是切斯特伯爵，是威尔士亲王。他知道他们有多棒。还有来自威尔士的弓箭手，也有来自兰开夏郡的。这是全国最好的，因此也是整个基督教世界最好的。是的。
Speak to anybody from Wales about the Middle Age. If it ever comes up, they will tell you Welsh archers won the Battle of Agincourt. That's what it's all about. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. And so these conting will tell you Welsh archers won the Battle of Agincourt. That's what it's all about. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. And so these contingents exclusively consist of archers. Contingents that are coming from elsewhere tend to be mixed in with men at arms. And I think under Edward III, these contingents had been pretty much 50-50.
和任何威尔士人谈论中世纪。如果谈到这个，他们会告诉你威尔士弓箭手赢得了阿金库尔战役。这就是它的全部意义。是的，绝对。是的。所以这些特遣队会告诉你威尔士弓箭手赢得了阿金库尔战役。这就是它的全部意义。是的，绝对。是的。所以这些特遣队完全由弓箭手组成。从其他地方来的特遣队往往与武装人员混在一起。我认为在爱德华三世统治下，这些特遣队差不多是五五开。
But under Henry V, the archers tend to outnumber men at arms about three to one. And I think that this reflects Henry's own decision. It's his innovation. And he'd introduced it in Wales. Maybe because he'd had that arrow, he'd been shot. It's kind of intensified for him his sense of just how dangerous this can be, and therefore how lethal. So Anne Currie's stats on this, of the expedition going to France, about 80% are archers, are longbowmen. So really that's a gamble though. That is a gamble.
但在亨利五世统治下，弓箭手的人数往往是武装人员的三倍左右。我认为这反映了亨利自己的决定。这是他的创新。他在威尔士引入了它。也许是因为他中过那支箭，他被射中了。这对他来说加剧了他对这有多危险，因此有多致命的感觉。所以安·柯里关于这次去法国的远征的统计数据，大约80%是弓箭手，是长弓手。所以这确实是一场赌博。这是一场赌博。
Because if the enemy close in, those archers, they're defenceless basically against enemy knights or whatever. It is a gamble, but it's a gamble that reflects Henry's years of campaigning in Wales. Right. And also the other thing that, of course, that Henry learnt in Wales is the fact that you need money and you need the supplies that money can then buy. He, again, has lots of experience of this. And so he's got Parliament on board. So Thomas Chaucer, who we mentioned, he'd been three-time Speaker. In November 1414, he'd become Speaker for a record fourth time. He raises a
因为如果敌人靠近，那些弓箭手，他们基本上对敌人的骑士或其他什么人毫无防备。这是一场赌博，但这是一场反映亨利在威尔士多年征战经验的赌博。对。而且亨利在威尔士学到的另一件事当然是，你需要钱，你需要钱能买到的补给。他再次对此有丰富的经验。所以他让议会站在了他这一边。所以我们提到的托马斯·乔叟，他曾三次担任议长。1414年11月，他创纪录地第四次成为议长。他筹集了一支
company. He's so enthusiastic. So he has 12 men at arms, 37 archers. So again, that's that one to three proportion. Sadly, Thomas Chaucer is invalided out before he can leave, but the archers and men at arms go. But in better news, Dick Whittington is on board. Dick Whittington is on board. So he's the mayor of London. He's rallying behind. Lots of loans. So it's all great. And so Henry, as a result, is able to raise certainly the largest force that had been mustered in England since the time of Edward III, maybe 12,000 men. This is a pretty formidable force. And his aim is a lot more than just a kind of cursory raid. His immediate target is Harfleur, that nest of pirates. If he can flush
连队。他太热情了。所以他有12名武装人员，37名弓箭手。所以再次，那是1比3的比例。遗憾的是，托马斯·乔叟在离开前因伤退役，但弓箭手和武装人员去了。但好消息是，迪克·惠廷顿加入了。迪克·惠廷顿加入了。所以他是伦敦市长。他正在支持。大量的贷款。所以这一切都很棒。因此，亨利能够筹集到自爱德华三世时代以来在英国集结的最庞大的部队，也许有12000人。这是一支相当强大的部队。他的目标不仅仅是一次草率的突袭。他的直接目标是哈弗勒尔，那个海盗窝。如果他能把它
that out and take it, then that would be brilliant. And maybe he could make it into a second Calais because the English hold Calais as a result of Edward III's wars. And if they can make Harfleur a second Calais, then that would be great. But Harfleur, because it's in Normandy, can also serve him as a launch pad for his kind of more ambitious plan, which is essentially to reclaim the Duchy of Normandy that William the Conqueror and his heirs had held. And he's clearly been preparing for this because when English ambassadors go to Paris, they've suddenly become quite keen on Henry's legal right to the Duchy of Normandy, which had actually ceased to exist, you know, maybe 200
清理出来并占领它，那将是极好的。也许他可以把它变成第二个加莱，因为英国人因为爱德华三世的战争而占领了加莱。如果他们能让哈弗勒尔成为第二个加莱，那将是极好的。但哈弗勒尔，因为它在诺曼底，也可以作为他更雄心勃勃计划的发射台，这个计划本质上是收复威廉征服者及其继承人所持有的诺曼底公国。他显然一直在为此做准备，因为当英国使节去巴黎时，他们突然对亨利对诺曼底公国的合法权利变得非常热衷，而这个公国实际上可能在200
years before. And the French are quite puzzled by this. I mean, they shouldn't have been. It's pretty clear why Henry would be interested in that. And on top of that, if you're going to take the very, very strongly fortified towns and castles of Normandy, you will need the latest weapon, which is cannon. And Henry IV had been a big fan of cannon. He'd fired them at Berwick. It was the first attack on a British city with cannon. And Henry V has inherited that enthusiasm. And he's commissioned all sorts of cannon in the Tower of London and takes with him to France the largest cannon ever forged in England. So it's all looking absolutely brilliant.
年前就已经不存在了。法国人对此感到非常困惑。我的意思是，他们不应该感到困惑。亨利为什么会对那个感兴趣是很清楚的。最重要的是，如果你要占领诺曼底防御非常、非常坚固的城镇和城堡，你将需要最新的武器，即大炮。亨利四世曾是大炮的忠实粉丝。他在贝里克发射过它们。这是第一次用大炮攻击英国城市。亨利五世继承了那种热情。他在伦敦塔委托制造了各种大炮，并带去了英国有史以来铸造的最大大炮。所以一切看起来绝对棒极了。
The invasion fleet is massing in the Solent, ready to cross to Normandy. And this is when a final French embassy appears in England in June 1415. Clearly, reports are coming in of what's happening and they're very, very nervous. So they offer Henry pretty generous terms and they are stunned when Henry turns them down. And the ambassadors leave with two parting shots. So one of them says to Henry, yeah, you've got all this stuff, but you're not going to do anything with it. It's going to be a hit and run raid. You know, you might loot a few fields, you might even capture a town, but you're not going to be able to do anything more than that. And that is hitting the spot because of course that is Henry's worry. He doesn't want that to happen. That's your argument. That was your argument
入侵舰队正在索伦特海峡集结，准备横渡到诺曼底。就在这时，1415年6月，最后一个法国使团出现在英国。显然，关于正在发生的事情的报告传来了，他们非常、非常紧张。所以他们向亨利提供了相当慷慨的条件，当亨利拒绝他们时，他们惊呆了。使节们带着两句临别赠言离开了。所以其中一个人对亨利说：“是的，你有所有这些东西，但你什么也做不了。这将是一次打了就跑的突袭。你知道，你可能会掠夺一些田地，你甚至可能占领一个城镇，但你将无法做任何更多的事情。”这正中要害，因为当然那是亨利的担忧。他不希望那样发生。那是你的论点。那是你的论点
about why he was overrated. That basically it was a fool's errand because France is too big to digest and that no English king can ever hope to do anything other than sack a town, burn some houses, capture a few knights, and then go home again, right? Right. But I think the French ambassador means less than that. He literally means you will just go and loot a few fields and maybe capture one town. And that's what Henry is worried about, because that will not rank as a success in the eyes of England and the world, if that is all he can do. He needs to do more than that with all the money, all the men,
关于他为什么被高估。基本上这是一项愚蠢的任务，因为法国太大而无法消化，而且没有英国国王能指望做任何事情，除了洗劫一个城镇，烧毁一些房屋，俘虏几个骑士，然后回家，对吧？对。但我认为法国大使的意思不止于此。他字面意思是，你只会去掠夺一些田地，也许占领一个城镇。而这正是亨利所担心的，因为如果他只能做到这些，那在英国和世界的眼中将不会被视为成功。他需要用他准备的所有金钱、所有的人、
all the kit that he's prepared. It has to be something more than that. And the other parting shot is from a bishop who's travelled with the embassy. And Henry says to the bishop, look, I'm the King of France. I have a legal right to the crown of France. And the bishop retorts, our sovereign Lord is the true King of France. And you have no right to any of the things you claim. You are no king, even in England, but merely one claimant among many,
所有的装备做更多的事情。它必须不仅仅是那样。另一句临别赠言来自一位随使团旅行的主教。亨利对主教说：“看，我是法国国王。我对法国王位有合法权利。”主教反驳道：“我们的主权君主是真正的法国国王。你对你所声称的任何事情都没有权利。你甚至在英国都不是国王，而仅仅是众多声称者中的一个，”
jostling for position with the true heirs of the late King Richard. I mean, that's punchy. Very, very punchy. That's below the belt, isn't it? It is. And it may well be because of that, that the revelation that hits Henry a few days later comes as an even greater blow than it already is. And this is the discovery of treason in his own retinue, because he's just preparing to embark at Southampton when he is approached by Edmund Mortimer, the Earl of March, who is the guy who people who are opposed to the House of Lancaster think should be king in Henry's place. Yeah, the alternative claimant. And Edmund Mortimer comes and he says, look, there's this conspiracy against you. And it
与已故国王理查的真正继承人争夺位置。我的意思是，那很有力。非常、非常有力。那是卑鄙的，不是吗？是的。而且可能正是因为那个原因，几天后传给亨利的消息对他来说是一个比已经发生的事情更大的打击。这就是在他自己的随从中发现了叛国罪，因为他正准备在南安普敦登船时，马奇伯爵埃德蒙·莫蒂默接近了他，他就是那些反对兰开斯特家族的人认为应该取代亨利成为国王的人。是的，替代声称者。埃德蒙·莫蒂默走过来说：“看，有一个针对你的阴谋。而且它
includes the younger brother of Edward the Duke of York, your own cousin, Richard of York. And he is preparing this plot. He wants to take me, make me king. He wants to kill you, get rid of you. So, you know, beware, this is in the footing. And Henry does some investigations and he discovers that, you know, this plot hasn't gone very far, so it's not looking actually that serious. But Richard of York, the guy who's leading this conspiracy, had sounded out one of Henry's closest advisors and friends, Henry Scrope, who's the nephew of the Archbishop who Henry IV had executed, but had always been kind of very close to Henry V.
包括约克公爵爱德华的弟弟，你自己的堂兄，理查·约克。他正在准备这个阴谋。他想带走我，让我成为国王。他想杀了你，除掉你。所以，你知道，小心，这就在脚下。”亨利做了一些调查，他发现，你知道，这个阴谋并没有走多远，所以看起来实际上并不那么严重。但领导这个阴谋的理查·约克，曾试探过亨利最亲密的顾问和朋友之一，亨利·斯克罗普，他是亨利四世处决的那位大主教的侄子，但一直与亨利五世非常亲近。
And Scrope had been completely contemptuous of the plot, said it's hopeless, you know, give it up. But he hadn't revealed it to Henry V. And so Henry is devastated by this. And when it's all revealed, he orders the execution, not just of Richard of York, but of Scrope as well. So this is not a good note on which to be leaving for France. Big old risk by Edmund mortimer to divulge the details
而斯克罗普对这个阴谋完全不屑一顾，说这毫无希望，你知道，放弃吧。但他没有向亨利五世透露。所以亨利对此感到崩溃。当这一切被揭露时，他下令处决的不仅是理查·约克，还有斯克罗普。所以这不是一个离开去法国的好心情。埃德蒙·莫蒂默冒了很大的风险去泄露
of a plot of which he is the focal point because henry could easily have said well i'll rub you out as well you're a threat to me yes except that i mean edmund mortimer is doing what scrape had failed to do right and scrape is executed for not revealing the plot whereas mortimer does reveal the plot and henry doesn't hold it against him isn isn't worried about him. No, and Mortimer is impeccably loyal to Henry V throughout his reign. Good for Mortimer. And I guess that this could have winded Henry, and it certainly focuses for him the nature of the risk that he is taking in going to France. There remain people who see him as a legitimate king. There are people who still want to bring the Lancastrian regime down and any hint of failure in France will be potentially fatal for Henry.
一个他自己是核心的阴谋的细节，因为亨利很容易说：“好吧，我也会把你抹掉，你对我是一个威胁。”是的，除了我的意思是，埃德蒙·莫蒂默正在做斯克罗普没能做到的事情，对吧？而斯克罗普因为没有揭露阴谋而被处决，而莫蒂默确实揭露了阴谋，亨利并没有因此而记恨他，并不担心他。不，而且莫蒂默在亨利五世统治期间一直对他无可挑剔地忠诚。莫蒂默做得好。而且我猜这可能让亨利喘不过气来，它确实让他专注于他去法国所冒风险的本质。仍然有人视他为合法国王。仍然有人想推翻兰开斯特政权，在法国的任何失败迹象对亨利来说都可能是致命的。
So he knows the gamble that he is taking. High risk though, Tom. Very, very high risk. But he's off 11th of August, 1415. Henry boards the largest ship in England. It had just been built for him in Greenwich, the Trinity Royal. He sails off at the head of a fleet of some 1,500 ships, which as Juliet Barker in her wonderful book on Agincourt points out, was a fleet 12 times the size of the Spanish Armada. And as they sail, very few people
所以他知道他正在进行的赌博。风险很高，汤姆。非常、非常高的风险。但他出发了，1415年8月11日。亨利登上了英国最大的船。它刚刚在格林威治为他建造，即“三位一体皇家号”。他率领一支约1500艘船的舰队起航，正如朱丽叶·巴克在她关于阿金库尔战役的精彩著作中所指出的，这支舰队的规模是西班牙无敌舰队的12倍。当他们航行时，很少有人
on the fleet know where they're heading. The French certainly don't know where they're heading. They cross the Channel. Two days later, the English fleet arrives in the Great Bay at the mouth of the Seine and the ships moor off a beach, off one of the headlands. And it's described by a priest who accompanies Henry on this expedition and who is an absolutely brilliant source for the entire campaign. He describes it as being very stony with large boulders dangerous to ships. So not the kind of place where a fleet would conventionally moor, but it's been chosen precisely because the French would not expect a landing there. And so therefore there are no defenders. And Henry looks out from his flagship at the scene. There is this rocky beach. There's a cliff, which is quite easy to climb, and it rises about 300
在舰队中知道他们要去哪里。法国人当然不知道他们要去哪里。他们横渡海峡。两天后，英国舰队抵达塞纳河口的伟大海湾，船只停泊在海滩外，在海角之一外。它被一位陪同亨利参加这次远征的牧师描述，他是整个战役的一个绝对精彩的来源。他描述它非常多石，有对船只危险的大块巨石。所以不是舰队通常停泊的地方，但它被选中正是因为法国人不会预料到在那里登陆。因此，没有防御者。亨利从他的旗舰上看着现场。这是一个岩石海滩。有一座悬崖，很容易攀爬，它上升了大约300
feet to a plateau. And Henry knows that about three miles beyond that plateau is his target, the port of Harfleur. What a cliffhanger. So if you would like to hear the next episode, you're a member of the Restless History Club, you don't need to do anything because it's right there waiting for you. If you'd like to join the rest is history club to hear it right away the battle of harfleur once more into the breach and all that business you can sign up at the rest is history.com otherwise we will see you next time for the next installment of this thrilling story merci tom et au revoir. A bientôt. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
英尺到一个高原。亨利知道，在那个高原之外大约三英里处是他的目标，哈弗勒尔港。多么悬念。所以如果你想听下一集，你是“其余历史俱乐部”的成员，你不需要做任何事情，因为它就在那里等着你。如果你想加入“其余历史俱乐部”立即收听，哈弗勒尔战役，再次冲入缺口以及所有那些事情，你可以在therestishistory.com注册，否则我们下次再见，继续这个激动人心的故事的下一部分。谢谢汤姆，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们一起主持《其余是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。